and the starting pitcher stats brought
to you by home furniture tonight there
aren't a whole lot of stats
for young
bayley over
look at him
here just
eight innings in uh in the big leagues
so far
strike three came back from 2-0 to
strike him out
less than 15 percent of the time
at the curve ball
that one
roped into right field for a base hit
michael brantley doing what michael
brantley does another base hit hitting
357 on the road but also
jeffers has seen the hitters ober has
not and that's a big help
up and in and a strikeout of bregman
he's drawing a walk
and that one's slapped to left field
on a line
and the astros have
two on with two outs in this first
inning
[Music]
[Applause]
big pop-up should end the inning simmons
wants it
a couple of hits do no damage of
scoreless first for bailey ober
[Applause]
jose archaney gets the start today for
the houston astros as he'll be going to
the mount his 11th start of the season
facing this minnesota twins team that he
dominated last year in the postseason
and jose kitty trying to bounce back
from a rough outing last time out yeah
that first start in june was not kind to
him up there in buffalo against the
toronto blue jays he does throw a lot of
strikes
and we know that if you do throw a lot
of strikes if you leave them out of the
zone they're going to get hit especially
from a young team like the toronto blue
jays
strike three call didn't even give him a
chance to breathe
a pitch punch out
it's two away
two down and now nelson cruz
to left center and deep nelson cruz
again
home runs in back to back at bats one to
end the game last night and now one to
start the game tonight
so they make you throw it in the strike
zone or very close to it
strike three call correa doesn't like it
[Music]
and buzzing in the outside corner with
the change-up
another good inning two more strikeouts
for bailey over
here is miguel cino
the left center and deep headed to the
bullpen there goes another one
a twin to the home run that cruz is
this man is just so strong is just
incredible incredible strength
and he got him looking he's picked up
five strikeouts in 10 played appearances
and three of them the last three have
been called third strikes two men in
scoring position for bregman
hit to center this will get a run home
so both runners advance and there's two
away the sacrifice fly and the astros
are on the board it's two to one
donaldson launches to left field and
deep that one's back towards the
bleachers and gone now the big boys all
having fun early tonight cruz suno
donaldson all three of homer and the
twins have a 3-1 lead
could be two
one
double play
and over faces just three men again in
the fourth
that one hit to right tucker coming in
and
that'll do it in the fourth
martini maldonado who had a pop fly
single now hits this one
to
left center field and
no problem at all for celestino and
there's one away
altuve's getting a nice welcome here by
the twins fans
that one is tagged left and
just foul wow
not by much that was a bullet or did he
that oh that's it that's a home run
gotta replay that if you're using an
asteroid
forget about it let's go take the stroll
yeah
this is the most unique home run
in jose altuve's career
change up got him five innings complete
over comes off the mound with the twins
in front three to two
julio for two couple of fly outs and
that one
hit deep to right to left field and that
ball is gone yulie guriel and that'll
tie it at three that is not easy to do
high octane up in the zone tomahawkit
tie this ball game up all of a sudden
here we are
to really tough spots where there's very
little margin for error
cinahl with a nice pickup alkaloid of
the bag got there just in time
nicely done by the first baseman of the
pitcher
[Applause]
hit well to center straw back straw on
the track and makes the catch we have
seen miles straw have problems with that
exact play in the past but not this time
on the ground carrail take the short
route and that will do it in the sixth
we go to the seventh inning astros and
twins tied at three
astros have a great chance here a
scoring threat without a hit
on the ground
simmons makes the play at first but the
astros will take the lead on the ground
out rbi
here's the pitch
got him strike three came with another
fastball
and their kitty picks up the strikeout
her kitty
delivers change up got a strike three
here keaney gets him and he picks up his
eighth strike out of the ball game and
it's a one two three seven
hit
sonole clean it up take care of it
himself three up three down for
shoemaker in the eighth
[Music]
in a home run and three trips tonight
driven to the right field corner and hit
well
gone
to the opposite field to tie the game
donaldson's second tonight his tenth of
the year and it's four apiece
two strikeouts
hit hard bregman has it comes up
throwing what a play
by alex bregman
shoemaker's set a backwards glance
another backwards glance now the pitch
and maldonado lines this one deep to
left field going back larnick still
going back and that will one hop off the
wall straw scores easily and maldonado
going into second base and he slides in
ahead of the offline throw with an rbi
double five four astros for the
minnesota twins just because you have
hansel robles out there that you were
talking about shot the other way and
that's an rbi single four hit night for
michael brantley maldonado scores and
it's six to four astros
morse on it
strike three called
and the astros with two runs in the
ninth inning
keep on rolling on this road trip